c'est le découragement pour Angela et
ses quatre enfants plus que 4 jours pour
déménager sans savoir encore où aller ça
fait longtemps que je cherche j'espère
que je vais trouver bientôt parce que
samedi on va on va être comme ça
depuis février elle cherche un logement
elle a un budget de 2500 dollars et elle
n'a essuyé que des refus
j'ai envoyé mes preuves de revenus
explique-t-elle et le propriétaire m'a
répondu que cinq personnes c'était trop
et ce type de réponse c'est lorsque les
propriétaires daignent faire un suivi à
ses demandes
Angela craint de devoir être hébergé
dans un centre pour sans abri
je n'aurais jamais cru ne pas pouvoir
trouver de logement c'est pas comme si
je n'avais pas les moyens
à Montréal ce sont 95 ménages qui sont
actuellement accompagnés par l'Office
municipal d'habitation pour trouver un
logement d'ici 4 jours l'an dernier 136
ménages ont été hébergés d'urgence au
lendemain du 1er juillet selon l'OMH il
y aurait une légère baisse des demandes
cette année merci d'avoir des enfants
particulièrement et un facteur de
discrimination qui est très très commun
c'est devenu chose courantes à l'heure
actuelle pour une famille qui sont dans
l'urgence de déménager à quelques jours
du 1er juillet entreprendre une démarche
là de pleine contre un propriétaire pour
victime de discrimination reste que
c'est pas nécessairement la priorité sur
le top la pile la Ville de Montréal
rappelle que la discrimination est
illégale et dit vouloir mettre fin au
cycle des crises du logement avec des
changements en profondeur
Angela n'a pas le temps d'attendre ses
changements elle poursuit ses recherches
et se prépare au pire ici Marie-José
paquet Comores au Canada Montréal